what did you do to Wally zerbiak I I  have no clue I know the name Wally  zerbiak I couldn't tell you where he  played I couldn't tell you what he did  as a basketball player I don't know he  had a lot to say about me I was really  like questioning like first who is this  and uh why is he talking about me like  this yeah so to set the stage he did he  called you what a wannabe All-Star I  don't know if I ever came out and said  like  I want to be an All-Star this year  please vote for me I didn't I didn't I  don't think I've done that yeah I don't  know I think he was just excited about a  Knicks win  um and that got him going but he's just  doing whatever he can to get attention  and that's just that's just the media  these days